welcome back to CBS this morning
impeachment cap the year that also
brought acts of shocking gun violence
and celebrations of patriotic
anniversaries that brought Americans
together this morning we are looking
back at all the pivotable
people and moments that helped shape
20:19 no collusion no obstruction
President Trump and his supporters say
Democrats they've gone too far with
claims of wrongdoing after robert muller
found the president did not collude with
russia this is pretty much as good as a
not guilty verdict while the russia
investigation is over the president's
legal problems continue I had a perfect
phonecall a totally perfect phone call
President Trump was accused of
withholding military aid to Ukraine in
exchange for Ukraine investigating the
Democrats what's there a quid pro quo
the answer is yes but has the two
articles of impeachment the president is
engaged well I did say I think this is
all going to blow up with hey we are
Democrats take control of the house the
entire freshman class was sent here
because Americans are sick of how
Washington works divisions among the
Democratic presidential hopefuls houston
we have a problem
candidates are trying to make their mark
at this crucial time in the race the
single most important thing we have to
accomplish is defeat Donald Trump
American troops are pulling back to make
way for turkeys planned invasion of
northern Syria it has been a tumultuous
time it was like a two-minute warning
he has to pack up and get moving because
the situation on the ground was about to
change dramatically and quickly the
daring raid in Syria killed Isis leader
Abu Bakr al Baghdadi closing the border
we'll keep it closed for a long time I'm
not playing games she says there's no
way she can go back to her home country
that things are much more dangerous
there's over 4,000 of the more than
10,000 children in the agency's care are
at risk of remaining in custody
long-term reports came out that they
were living in horrible conditions
you're saying this is not good enough
I've been saying it for a year massacres
in El Paso Texas and Dayton Ohio
happened in startling proximity for a
country too familiar with gun violence
no children in any world should see
things like that they shouldn't
the hate crime category you have the
church category you have the school
category bottom line it is dead as a
category this is one of New Zealand's
darkest days never thought of my life
for them to see some mothers the Prime
Minister vows to reform her country's
gun laws in response to the worst mass
shooting in the country's modern history
51 lives were lost from a Muslim
community than a question was asked you
know why does anyone need military-style
semi-automatic weapons or assault rifles
so that's where we drew the line
hurricane durian ravages the Bahamas
[Music]
everything on one time one side of the
405 was turned into a towering inferno
if you're filled there you're an idiot
get the hell out boeing faces safety
questions after the second deadly crash
of one of its new 737 max eight jets you
now have 346 tombstones this is not an
accident this is something that could
have been prevented I would walk before
I was to get on a 737 max
[Music]
Oh
Parliament came no closer to proving
terms of its breakup with Europe it is a
burning desire to get brexit
China's central government is condemning
protests in Hong Kong what started off
as a peaceful protest has devolved on
stands damaged but defiant after a fire
raged for at least 12 hours and so that
means not just building embattled singer
R Kelly is in custody for the second
time this year on federal sex crime
charges now he isn't facing years he's
facing decades Jeffrey Epstein was
charged with sex trafficking and
conspiracy the alleged sex ring may have
involved dozens of underage girls were
you afraid of him yeah I mean that he's
dead but I still AM Epstein may be gone
but the demand for justice is
intensifying you could not spend time
around him and not know lawyers want
Prince Andrew to cooperate with
investigators
keeping the prince in the spotlight even
as he tries to step away from it as far
as I was aware they worst off he knows
what happened I know what happened and
there's only one of us telling the truth
an explosive new HBO documentary Wade
Robson and James safe to claim Jackson
used them for years when they were young
children critics are calling it shocking
saying you'll never listen to Michael
Jackson the same way again how can we
provide comfort for other survivors
that's what this is about and Michael
just happens to be the abuser in this
child sexual abuse story prosecutors
accused dozens of people including two
Hollywood stars of paying millions to
get their kids into top schools these
were parents who were cutting the line
illegally
and taking their kids along for the ride
the number of cases of severe lung
illness possibly caused by vaping has
surged and how do you sit here and sell
it every day we have a product and does
not present a risk the message to teens
is clear no device is safer than tube
eight thirteen year old Jamie Claus who
disappeared the day her parents were
murdered escaped from captivity and she
is safe it's such an overwhelming happy
ending to such a horrible beginning sure
we're home
here's to the wall that we got G to the
wish you were here but you're not cuz
the drinks bring back all the memories
of everything we've been through toss to
the ones the Kurdish after those to the
world to be lost on the way cuz of Jews
bring back all the memories and the
memories bring back memories bring back
[Music]
so you can bless others
god bless somebody Saturday come on
can't we shout to call you wonder what
will be will be
[Music]
okay take the firm hold of the
hypodermic needle right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
our medicine
[Music]
what is not playing last for not one two
three one two three no don't do that
goodbye fans of Britain's royal family
around the world are celebrating yes we
are the newest addition to the family
the Duke and Duchess of Sussex have a
7-pound 3-ounce baby boy this little
thing is is obviously Stifel fifty years
ago the Apollo 11 mission blasted off
half a century later historians tend to
agree it still stands as perhaps
humanity's greatest achievements to date
City Mason is in Normandy
he's leaving our d-day anniversary
coverage I'm always struck by the
gravity and enormity of what happened
here it's almost incomprehensible it's
the first time I took Omaha Beach sand
for 75 years as a field
I feel stamping what does
he was telling the truth somebody tell
us who edited that that was really
really only talking about it because
it's that when you look over the stuff
that happened the past year you know I
can't believe that happened who did Eva
let us put it together la Velez thank
you thank you very much Katie Kathleen
and Camilla Bravo cuz that is hard to do
that is very hard to always at the end
of every year but I can't believe how
much one year yeah I always enjoy
looking at those it's everything in
perspective and makes you realize how
fortunate we are really that we are
still here